as of 11 o'clock British time this
morning uh the sort of processing center
the uh reception team of Border force
and foreign office we're now uh up and
running uh on the Airfield in Sudan uh
they'd been brought from the UK or
indeed Cyprus Through the Night by our
forces and we now have approximately uh
120 British forces at the Airfield
supporting uh
the delivery of the evacuation of
Nationals and dual Nationals through the
airport currently the Airfield is run by
the German military
um and depending on how long they stay
we will stand ready or prepared to take
over from them should they decide that
their evacuation is finished there is
obviously the 72-hour ceasefire which is
a window
but it is volatile situation I do want
to place a record my thanks to Sydney's
Armed Forces who are happy to host us at
their Airfield and indeed import sedan
on the Red Sea which I've driven to make
sure is an alternative location and well
it is 500 miles away from Khartoum
across you know the desert it is a more
benign environment and it is an access
into the Red Sea and into commercial
airports and places like Jeddah and
gives us space and time in order to
process any people there
well these are the latest pictures of
royal Marine Commandos boarding an
aircraft from the RAF criteria base in
Cyprus officials said they will contact
those who are eligible for evacuation
directly
urging British Nationals not to make
their way to the Airfield unless they're
called